- On this episode we talk about zip codes.
We talk about valuations
and we talk about hustle.
What else?
You ask questions and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and you're watching and listening
to The #AskGaryVee
Show episode number 32.
Little fun fact about the number 32,
32 is the number worn by Josh Bush
who is the New York Jets' safety,
who got cut yesterday off the team.
The Jets also play tonight
against the New England Patriots,
the team I hate more than
anything in the world.
Before I get into today's questions,
sorry Steve someone will
have to do that again,
I want to give a shout-out to
the person that gave me that.
I find it interesting that the person
that gave me the little
prop for today's show
actually backchanneled
with the whole crew here
to get a shout-out on the show.
I find that growth hackery
but also a little spammy.
She wants a shout-out and I'm not going
to do it the way she thinks.
I'm actually going to go to her right now.
DRock get up. I know I'm
throwing you a curveball.
I know if you're listening
right now you have no idea
what's going on but
that's just the way it's gonna have to be.
So Nicky gave me the
prop and my question is
did she give me the prop
because she's a good person
or did she give me a prop
because she just wanted
to get a shout-out
- No it's just because I
love the Knicks so much.
- I understand but wouldn't
you say it's a little selfish.
That sounded a little
bit like a humble brag.
I mean you made it a point
for them to tell me that
you wanted a shout-out.
So now we're giving you
an extreme shout-out.
- Hey guys!
- I mean were you going for the shout-out
or were you going for-
Give me the percentage breakdown
of your love of the Knicks
versus your own personal
selfish I want a shout-out on the show?
Tell the truth lying is the devil.
- I don't lie.
- Okay
- The Knicks are always
over everything else.
- That's fine what percentage
breakdown? You comped out.
- 95.
- For the Knicks?
- Yes.
- Five for personal gain?
- Why not?
- Fair, alright it's only 5 percent
personal gain I'm cool with that.
Alright DRock keep coming.
It's right here I don't
want you to get hurt.
You're going to probably edit.
You like to edit. Right?
- [DRock] No.
- No, no editing? Alright.
Alright, now, now with Melo intact.
Here's a humble brag, Melo
once sat in this exact seat
actually and freaked
out the whole company.
That was a lot of fun the other day.
Alright, let's get into the questions.
- [Voiceover] Alex asks "Gary,
do you consider it possible
to hustle the way you do anywhere outside
of the United States?"
- Alex this is a ludacris question.
It is complete- Do we
know where Alex is from?
Maybe you can look it up real quick
while i'm answering this question.
Alex this is a ludacris question.
This question pisses me off so much
that it's starting to start
to show with it, as Steve is looking.
The thought and nature of people saying
well America is an
entrepreneurial paradise
is the same conversation that's happening
within America of like to
be great in tech you need
to be in San Francisco,
like no good businesses
are made outside of Silicon Valley.
That is just asenine.
Let me just remind everybody
that Facebook was invented in Boston.
Alright, and the home of the Patriots
It's crazy for me when people debate this.
Of course you can.
Your country is not the variable
of your hustle life, right?
Now the environment that
entrepreneurship is glorified
in the US. The UK wants
to be more reserved.
China got it's own version
of entrepreneurship.
Yes, does the environment
effect it? Of course.
My parents growing up in soviet Russia
where there was no business,
of course they were effected by that.
But your hustle, your work ethic,
your drive is not
predicated on your zip code.
- [Voiceover] Tony asks,
"Gary, what are your thoughts
about people that say
companies like Twitter, Uber,
and Snapchat are way
overvalued in the market?"
- Tony, what's really
interesting about this quesiton
is I am one of those people.
I grew up in the late and mid 2000s
into the 2010s 11s, 12s, 13s
thinking a lot of things were overvalued.
I thought we were at a little bit
of a bubble in 2010, 11.
I've been proven to be extremely wrong.
What I would tell you is,
is that inflation happens.
The world changes.
I'm starting to wrap my head the notion
of wait a minute maybe
these things are undervalued
because the value of a
hundred million dollar compnay
just 15, 20, 30 years
ago was a far grander
and wealth just contines
to exponentially grow
and so I would say that,
it's a double-edged sword.
There wil be prenty of
things over valued, tons.
But if something is proven to have won
and you think is the
future of infrastrucure.
A la an Uber, where you
can clearly see them getting
into FedEx and UPS lanes in other places.
Plenty of people have lost a lot of money
by thinking things were overpriced.
And I want you to listen to
that backwards one more time.
So rewind it whether you're
listening or watching.
A lot of people have lost
a lot of money by thinking
things have been overvalued.
And of course there's
the ying to that yang
and pople have lost in
betting on overvalued things
but when things hit scale Amazon and Ebay
in the early days of the internet
where people thought they were overvalued
but the world caught up to them.
Be careful if the world is
catching up to something.
What I mean by that is
if you start watching
normal people doing things
on some of these platforms
you're going to see a scale jump
Are they overvalued?
If there's a crash in the market
or a terrorist attack in a
major city, can it be overvalued?
Of course, but is that
temporary is the real question.
And when I say temporary
don't misunderstand me.
Is it overvalued and
will go down for a year
but then go back up because they're living
in the future while other things are not.
- [Voiceover] Annie Hubbard asks
"For blogs just starting
out, how do I get people
to be interviewed without
being a big name media company?"
- Annie your question really means
to me, which is how do I go out
and get people where I can
take their brand equity
as a starting point for mine, right?
Like if I could interview Gary Vee
and put it out there some
of his fans will come over,
listen to that interview and
then they'll become aware of me.
So what you're talking about
is equity leveraging arbitrage.
Brilliant, agree with it, for
the people that are listening.
If you look at podcast land
that's how they all do it.
I did a bunch of those interviews
promoting Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook
and then they're leveraging my name over
and over and over again
to build auidience.
So it is a classic game.
There's a dirty little secret Annie.
People that have leverage and have fame
even if you call it z-level fame, like me.
They like to talk and so I'm going
to tell you something that kind of refers
to question number one on this episode
which is the answer is hustle.
I would just keep asking
and asking and asking.
I would audit all the
places that look like you
or kind of like you and look at the people
that have done interviews there
and when you start realizing that I
and Tim Ferriss and Seth Godin like
to give interviews because
we also like the exposure.
We also have been successful
and we like to give back.
I loved, a couple of
years ago, or last year,
my interview 365 day year thing
where I just gave people interviews
that didn't even have any audience
because I was giving back.
Some don't want to give
interviews unless you're big.
That's why you get nos others do it
because they like to pay
back to the community
and they remember grinding and the person
that gave them a break.
And so very honestly I
would ask and oh by the way,
I got a real curveball for you
and this is for everybody listening.
Sometimes you need to ask
the same person 11 times.
And one could say that
you're being annoying
but if you come from a good place
and you do it with a prideful tack
and you do it in an appropriate way
and if you're actually listening
to what's going on in their world
maybe Tim's got a new book coming out.
Maybe he redesigned his website.
Maybe he's got a new podcast.
Those are times to strike like a cobra
when they want something
and you want something,
then interests align.
- [Voiceover] NCG asks "What does one do
when you feel you have unique content
but not tapping into the right audience
or not gaining visibility."
- Nikola, this is where you start
looking yourself in the mirror
and deciding if you have
business development chops.
This notion that you
have the greatest content
and it's not finding
it's audience is romantic
at worst and audacious at best.
To me what you need to
look at is are you capable
of also building audience for your content
or are you just the content provider
and do you need a partner
who can help you go out
and do that or have
you just lost all sense
of reality and you're
stuff is just average.
- [Voiceover] Galen asks, "At
what point do you just get rid
of a client because they are
just an all around clown?"
- Galen, this is a funny question.
I think a lot of VaynerMedia
employees are going
to have a fun time with this quesiton
if they are watching or listening.
I think that for me I
hold on for dear life.
First of all business is business.
I think one of the reasons
people recommend getting rid
of clients is they don't have
the stomach for adversity.
I actually can deal with the negativity
and it's business is business.
If they fire me then I
deserved to be fired.
But the notion of there
are clients to be fired.
It's right and a lot of
times it helps your business
and so it's about self-awareness.
So for me, Galen, it's
very late in the process,
like almost borderline, I don't know,
when they take a knife and
stab it through your eye.
It might not be a good
relationship anymore
but that's literally the level
that I'm looking forward to
because I can handle it and
it's not slowing me down.
We've got plenty of clients that I think
by all modern standards
should have been fired
but I have not and it has
not hindered the growth
because yes there's some time
and attention put into that
and even in a world where
we get lots of new business.
There is value in retention.
There's also moods.
How about relationships?
Do you just get divorced
when a time comes tough?
The ebb and flow. Do you
just get rid of a best friend
because of a bad night?
Do you get rid of friend
after six straight bad nights?
One could argue yes but I'd
say hmm there's a lot there
that you may want to fight for it.
So I think it comes
down to self-awareness.
A lot of people are not capable
of dealing with the conflict
or it brings them down.
To me, I like to rise to that challenge.
I like that game but it comes down
to my own self-awareness of me as a leader
and more importantly i have
to factor in the empathy
of 400 other people and
is it bringing them down.
So cool, I can stomach it but
as they're getting yelled at
on the phone every single day,
is it bringing them to a
place where they want to leave
and so for me it's when
it's effecting other people
that are in my family that I value more
and family I mean my company
that I value more than the client itself.
That's when I'm looking at
it but then a lot of times,
I'm trying to surround,
interchange and account people
of the people that have more of my stomach
and can handle it.
To me, that is the timing.
Thanks for watching episode
32 of the #AskGaryVee Show.
I really want to just take a quick second
and give a huge shout-out
and then honestly,
you guys know how I roll because
It's been a lot of jabbing.
Coming in with a little
right hook on this episode.
I really just want to thank everybody
who's been supporting my
transition to an adding a podcast
to that, to this whole genere.
And really just supporting the show,
with 32 episodes in this
is not my first rodeo.
I'm really enjoying it
and so I want to ask
for some love on all the people
that are interested in subscribing
to the podcast on iTunes
and all the other places
that we're now playing with
which is a lot of fun. Are
we confirmed everywhere?
Alex, where are we at now at this point?
- We're on Stitcher, iTunes, Overcast,
we're still working with them.
- Meaning that some of the
episodes haven't been play there.
So we're husting
- and Soundcloud
- What's that?
- Soundcloud.
- Soundcloud. India just cause
I like showing new people
in the room.
- What else?
- I just wanted to catch you
off guard. Nope, that was it.
I know that's not even your world
but that was just fun for me,
that was just a personal haha for me.
So I really appreciate and
the one thing I guess I need
to continue the flow is the rating of it.
And by the way if that rating is a one
and you don't like the show.
One star on iTunes, knock yourself out
and you know what, I'm noticing
a lot of you not subscribing
on YouTube. I need that action as well.
So I appreciate you
allowing me a minute here
to throw some right hooks.
I hope they all land 'cause I'm hustling.
- Oh crap, wait subsrcibe
I need subscriptions because I can't push
this many right hooks
in social so subscribe!